bitcoin and crypto's crashing and
everyone's freaking out one of the
things that's happening in the industry
as well is that many of the equity-based
companies coinbase block fight and many
others they're all laying off 15 to 20
of their staff now before you start to
wonder what the hell is going on are
these companies going away it's
important to understand that any
industry when there's any sort of
recession or downturn in the macro
environment they start to hunker down
they start to prepare for the worst they
want to make sure that they survive the
bear market and crypto is no different
what we are seeing is that many of the
venture-backed companies many of the
public companies and many of the
equity-based companies they're all
hunkering down they want to make sure
that they have strong balance sheets
they want to get their expenses under
control they want to ensure that they
can get to profitability and also get to
the other side of the bear market to
understand how these companies are
thinking about it we've got a couple of
quotes here from brian armstrong the ceo
of coinbase he said we appear to be
entering a recession after a 10 plus
year economic boom a recession could
lead to another crypto winter and could
last for an extended period while it's
hard to predict the economy or the
markets we always plan for the worst so
we can operate the business through any
environment he then went on to state our
employee costs are too high to
effectively manage this uncertain market
while we tried our best to get this just
right in this case it is now clear to me
that we have over hired we should expect
to see layoffs at many companies and
there's likely to be more to come but
this isn't a reason to panic instead
this should be expected of course it
doesn't feel great for the people who
are being laid off and it doesn't feel
great for people in the industry that
we're counting on those companies for
future employment but what we have to
understand is that these companies are
simply becoming more efficient and they
are preparing themselves to be able to
survive for months sometimes even years
of a bear market now of course that
doesn't mean that the bear market will
last that long it just means that
they're overly prepared which is a good
thing and so naturally as you see the
layoffs just understand that this is an
activity that these companies are going
through to get costs under control and
to make sure that their balance sheets
can handle anything that the macro
environment throws at them the federal
reserve is increasing interest rates
they're conducting quantitative
tightening no one knows what is going to
happen in the future the best thing that
a company can do whether you're in the
crypto industry or not whether you're a
large company or a small company is to
simply be prepared be able to weather
the storm if you can get to the other
side that's usually means that you've
got a great business and one that's got
a strong enough foundation to thrive
during the good times hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time